My previous holistic practitioner said from blood work that I was pre-diabetic.
Late onset type 1, she had me had a couple supplements that were supposed to help regulate my
blood sugar. Desides for health, burberry and synergy, mitochondrial energy,
of which I am no longer taking. I did take this diagnosis very seriously since I had not been
symptomatic. As far as I knew, it felt very good while hungry or
intermittent fasting, or even fasting for several days, even while I was a vegan this winter.
However, I now, in the past two to four weeks, feel like my metabolism is on hyperdribe.
And I wake up, depleted and weak and lightheaded.
So, understand if you have diabetes, you have the inability to get blood sugar into the cell
because of damaged cell membrane receptors, talking about type 2 diabetes.
If you truly have late onset type 1 diabetes, then you have antibodies
to the island cells in the pancreas that make insulin. So, that's a totally different type
of diabetes. So, really a totally different disease, though, it'll manifest from a blood sugar level
meeting, measuring blood glucose levels with something as simple as a glucometer, like this is
is elevated blood glucose, the same as diabetes type 2. So, then you have to find out by testing
antibody levels, whether you have antibodies to take your island cells. So, that's how you would
diagnose type 1 diabetes. If you do have type 1 or type 2 diabetes, have it in metabolism and
hyperdribe, really, I mean, it turns out how you're defining need metabolism and hyperdribe. But
and feeling and waking up, feeling depleted and weak and lightheaded, really wouldn't be the symptoms
necessarily of diabetes. That would be more the symptoms of waking up depleted and weak and
lightheaded would be more the symptoms of hypoglycemia. And then when you measure your glucose
of the morning, you'd have very suppressed glucose levels. It takes me a long time in the morning to
get enough food for me to keep to feel better. Really again, that's really not the symptom
diabetes. Again, the way you diagnose diabetes is, technically, if you have blood glucose levels,
the fasting blood glucose levels of more than one incidence of over 125
decilier leaders per microgram. So, on a blood monitoring, sugar would be over 125, where it says
104 on this, after 10 or 12 hour fast. And it has to be more than one instance. This morning,
I crashed in terrible shaky week, weekness. So, that would be signs of hypoglycemia.
And that can happen with someone with diabetes, but that happens with somebody with diabetes,
whether on insulin, and they're taking too much insulin. So, it's bringing their blood sugar
level to low. So, it's a hypoglycemic instance in diabetes because of excess use of insulin, not
monitoring that well enough. So, that's what you want to look for. Get yourself a glucose
ometer if you don't have one, and start measuring your glucose levels in the body. That's
well, but let's go to the whole page of the member site, and download that chart, and start
keeping track of that. I'm supposed to begin chemo next week. Can you imagine surviving this
very fragile? So, make sure you monitor that, get your blood glucose levels, and your blood levels
are balanced.